bonjour violaine dire un merci de
répondre à nos questions anakin rats
hydroxy chloroquine azithromycine reine
des civières finalement aucun traitement
ne semble efficace à 100% quel espoir de
trouver le remède miracle un jour
bonjour je n'ai pas de conflit d'intérêt
je tiens à préciser
et puis je voudrais les rassurer quand
même la population par rapport à ce que
la jeune femme vient de dire il y a des
solutions de soins dans les hôpitaux
privés des cliniques privées donc il
faut arrêter de se stresser la
population il ya également des
traitements en phase précoce qui doivent
être utilisés pour précisément éviter
les passages en hospitalisation
donc effectivement nous avons appris une
communication sur la nac inra qui en
fait il faut savoir c'est c'est une
molécule qui est extrêmement bien connue
des rhumatologues en particulier
puisqu'elle est utilisée dans les
polyarthrite rhumatoïde et un certain
nombre de syndrome inflammatoire depuis
au moins 2015 puisqu'elle à son
autorisation de mise sur le marché en
2015 en france
c'est un laboratoire suédois qui l'a
mise au point et c'est un laboratoire
qui est dédié aux médicaments orphelins
donc ces médicaments qui traitent des
maladies rares et qui sont souvent des
petits marchés c'est une molécule qui
est immunosuppressives et qui est
extrêmement potentiellement intéressante
parce qu'elle bloque le récepteur de
l'interleukine a un qui est une molécule
qui responsable de cette phase
inflammatoire qui crée des dégâts
pulmonaire en particulier mais vous en
tendant et de santé ce que vous
prescrivez à un patient un malade
atteint du du corona virus vous avez la
liberté presque oui on a retrouvé on va
dire la liberté de prescrire moi
personnellement selon les cas cliniques
je vais prescrire de l'asie trop me
simpson 2
trop nissin plus du zinc de l'asie trop
mais si nos de lait et de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine ça dépend de la clinique et
moi je vois des patients en phase
précoce c'est à dire en ville et avant
que je le reconnais étaient annulés non
récemment on sait qu'ils avaient une
lettre notamment de renaud muselier pour
venir en soutien au professeur dédi
round en fait on a le droit de les
prescrire mais or on est dans un cadre
aurait même donc ça doit être une
prescription en accord avec le médecin
et le patient ça c'est très important
après il faut trouver des médecins qui
n'ait pas peur effectivement puisqu'on a
reçu des courriers des conseils de
l'ordre des médecins et des pharmaciens
nous rappelant que lorsqu on le faisait
ce qu'on faisait ça on était
éventuellement passibles s'ils y avait
des des dépôts de plainte contre les
patients des de la part des patients
pardon contre les médecins que nous
n'étions que nous étions dans un cadre
juridique particulier mais bon moi j'ai
l'habitude par exemple pour certaines
contraception qui n'ont pas du tout eu
d'autorisation de mise sur le marché
dans l'indication contraception donc un
certain nombre de progestatifs en
particulier de prescrire y est
normalement en franche de produits qui
sont prescrits en ryan alors pour
revenir sur les nac inra parce que c'est
quelque chose d'assez intéressant
il y avait des publications et ça a
commencé en fait en italie
le professeur
comment s'appelle-t-il cavalli à rome
fait une première publication chez des
patients qui étaient dans un stade grave
et a priori bon c'était un tout petit
échantillon on peut dire que c'était une
étude préliminaire qui a montré un
intérêt de cette molécule qui
normalement sur l'éthique à manger des
prescrits en injection sous cutanée
mais dans le cas du coc vide les équipes
qui ont fait des études l'utilisant
nappe en forme intraveineuse
ensuite nous avons eu des équipes
françaises qui ont testé cette molécule
en particulier à l'hôpital de la
conception à marseille
l'équipe du professeur kaplan ce qui là
il ya eu un échantillon un petit peu
plus important de personnes et cette
première étude qui a été publié dans une
revue internationale qu'on appelle tnf
montrait un intérêt potentiel de cette
molécule
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya de l'espoir
quand même et simplement je me permets
de vous de vous couper pour revenir
jusqu'à c est quand même très technique
mais pour revenir sur question beaucoup
plus général on sait qu'il ya le
couvre-feu le confinement les français
qui s'y perdent sur la stratégie
sanitaire nationale quand on écoute les
politiques mais les français qui savent
ou par ipsos technique vous êtes une
scientifique les français qui s'y
perdent aussi quand on écoute les
scientifiques maladie 100 malades pour
les uns comme le professeur toussaint
par exemple appel à suréquiper des
hôpitaux comme le professeur jules 20
utilisées telles molécules ou telle
molécule anakin rallye de russie
chloroquine reine des environs s'y perd
qui croit on est perdu sur tous les
plans vous comprenez le désarroi des
français
alors je comprends et ce qu'elle trouve
important de rappeler aux français s'est
fait comme d'habitude quand vous avez un
syndromes de type grippal parce que
c'est ce qu'on appelle les syndromes de
type grippal des courbatures de la
fièvre et différents petits symptômes
parce qu'on est en plein en automne dans
ces syndromes de type grippal qui
peuvent être liés à la grippe à la
grippe dès des rhinovirus adéquat rona
virus et bien qu'est ce que vous faites
d'habitude vous prenez votre téléphone
vous appelez votre médecin traitant et
vous bien demander une consultation pour
qu'il vous examine et ça c'est
fondamental
et si les
des malades font ça on n'aura pas de
problème ils vont être ausculté si
jamais il ya des signes pulmonaires à
l'auscultation et bien les médecins vont
faire ce qu'ils font d'habitude c'est à
dire qu'ils vont éventuellement faire
une radio voire un scanner thoracique et
traiter les patients on traite les
patients avec des antibiotiques c'est
aussi une des éléments de base on traite
les patients souvent avec des macrolides
quand il ya des signes pulmonaires
donc c'est une classe de médicaments
dont fait partie des titres aux missiles
et je sais qu'il ya beaucoup de
confusion qui est actuellement jetez y
compris dans auprès des médecins puisque
nous avons reçu des dessins des mails de
la direction générale de la santé qui
dit aux médecins généralistes de ne pas
prescrire l'azithromycine et bon mois
ayant fait une étude publiée au niveau
international montrant l'intérêt de
l'asie trop micinn seul dans cette
pathologie du coc vide
je ne peux pas adhérer à ce qui est dit
actuellement
merci de nous donner voilà nous sommes
plusieurs mais tient à avoir communiqué
sur le sujet ya énormément de
publications internationales et en cinq
ans vous quand on vous entend il ya de
l'espoir merci violet de vieira d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
merci à vous je rappelle que vous êtes
médecin et donc membre du collectif
laissons les prescrire